imagine a planet of endless sand and
scorching sun
a world where every day is a race for
survival and every night a fearsome
competition for resources the infamous
desert planet of tatooine located in a
galaxy far far away is known for being
an inhospitable wasteland yet the
creatures that brave this unforgiving
environment are truly fascinating and
possess hidden intricacies that deserve
to be studied further
so for this entry into the archive i'll
be documenting this arid biosphere first
hand analyzing the biology of these
extreme life forms and seeing how their
survival strategies compare to those
present in earth's deserts so join me in
a landspeeder on this voyage across the
desert as we uncover the mysteries of
tatooine
the planet of tatooine orbits a rare
binary star system meaning it has two
suns with the smaller sun in a stable
orbit around the larger one
on the surface of tatooine one can
certainly feel the heat of both suns at
all times as can the animals that live
here beginning our journey on the vast
expanse known as the dune sea life in
this region is highly specialized to
survive the merciless heat
peering through my macro binoculars i
spot a group of woolly banthas these
hearty megafauna are the preferred
method of transportation for the local
tuscan populace in a staple of tatooine
wildlife a large furry animal might seem
poorly suited for a hot desert
environment but we can find a desert
life form with a similar strategy in the
earth camel
camels are experts at keeping cool in
part through specialized shaggy fur that
helps keep their body temperatures low
to prevent excess moisture loss so it's
likely the banthas can enter the deserts
of tatooine thanks to similar
adaptations
but beating the heat is one thing to
survive on tatooine the banthas must
also find food and water to discover the
bantha's food source one must dig
underground this is a black melon a
cactus-like species which like many
forms of cacti is a precious source of
water in this arid ecosystem
once again earth camels supplement their
bulk with a similar food source grazing
on cacti whenever they get the chance
while you or i might struggle to stomach
plants like this it's no trouble for
desert specialists like the camel or the
bantha
so while the dune sea seems barren the
surprisingly dense network of
underground vegetation means large
creatures such as the bantha don't go
hungry
if they know where to look
but it's not just the banthas who drink
of the black melon the tuscan clans a
group of mysterious sapient lifeforms
that call this unforgiving desert their
home also know all the ins and outs of
the dune sea i initially hoped to
document some of their knowledge but
tuscans are highly distrustful of
off-worlders
they weren't interested in conversing
without their masks or even with them so
my questions about this planet's ecology
go unanswered for now
feeling my welcome is well past worn out
it's time i set off on my landspeeder
once more and document the next life
form of tatooine
heading through a nero canyon i spot a
fearsome massive and unfortunately for
me these mid-sized reptilian predators
move in packs coordinating in intricate
groups to take down their prey
the massive pack structure is similar to
those of spotted hyenas on earth with
both species living in large factions
that coordinate to apprehend animals far
larger than themselves and sharing in
the spoils once the hunt is over
fortunately for me this pack
surprisingly isn't wild but are the
domesticated allies of the same tuscan
clan i spoke to before as it turns out
domesticated massive serve as loyal
guard dogs across tuscan societies
deciding to spend another night with the
clan i learn more about the massives
like how their dorsal spines aren't just
for defense but also show the creature's
age through their length and although
i'm still a little worried the massives
haven't stopped thinking about eating me
i'm excited to find the tuscans are
opening up to my questions
a tuscan storyteller i interview informs
me that their people believe that
thousands of years ago tatooine was
covered in rainforest and the dune sea
itself was an ocean of flowing water
such an extreme transformation might
seem unlikely but shells and other
fossils found in the dune sea on a prior
expedition corroborate this theory the
process by which fertile land becomes
desert is called desertification
and it seems this process began on
tatooine around 25 000 years ago
some claim the desertification of
tatooine was brought on by off-world or
activity while others theorize it was a
natural process caused by the planet's
twin suns in any case it's something
i'll have to keep in mind as i consider
the lineage of the species that live
here
the next morning a commotion stirs
through the camp a trap has caught a
nocturnal wart twisting out the
toad-like creature careens across the
sand typically warts are most active at
night where they feed on rodents like
womp rats and anything else they can
ambush with their shockingly long
tongues
these tongues resemble those of earth
chameleons which can also lash out with
amazing speed at unsuspecting prey like
the wart the chameleon's tongue is
stretchable to almost twice the animal's
length and is powered by spirally wound
protein fibers which can store energy
like a stretched rubber band
yet soon this predator will become prey
one quick blaster bolt
and it's all over this wart will help
feed the clan and their massives a
little longer to survive on tatooine one
must take what one can get
setting off towards the western reaches
a spot in the distance an intimidating
creature rising up from the sand
this six-limbed feral beast is a
tatooine sand date its target is a wild
massif which the giant sand ape makes
short work of
this is not a creature one should mess
with while their name and muscular
anatomy mirrors large primates like
gorillas the sand apes ambush hunting
strategy is actually much closer to a
very different kind of life form
in the sahara desert a slightly smaller
predator swims under the sand the sand
fish is a type of reptile that buries
itself within the dunes then when prey
gets close enough it surfaces and
snatches it up just like the sand ape of
tatooine and now that the sand ape has
subdued the massif it's time to head in
the other direction before it makes me
its next meal
cresting over a sand dune i spot a herd
of lethargic dewbacks these
thick-skinned reptiles are frequently
used as mounts both by travelers and
those of a more sinister nature their
name however comes from their seldom
glimpsed habit of licking the morning
dew from their backs to stay hydrated a
desert animal drinking collected dew
might sound miraculous but namab desert
beetles which i've discussed on this
channel before actually have a
convergent survival strategy on misty
desert mornings they stand on their
heads and let the dew that collects on
their backs drip down into their mouths
and with fog in the air today these
dewbacks likely have the same idea on a
world with twin suns all water is
precious
but there are far more dangerous
creatures under the twin suns i've yet
to document rancors are massive
predators prized in the underground
market for their fighting capabilities
paying to study one specimen i've found
they live up to their fearsome
reputation with their long arms they
seem somewhat unsteady on two feet with
a posture reminiscent of the fighting
stance of a territorial grizzly bear
with their long claws and powerful brawn
grizzlies are perhaps the closest thing
on earth to a rancor
on their hind legs these bears can tower
over seven feet or two meters tall but
as imposing as grizzlies are a
full-grown rancor can easily reach 16
feet or 5 meters tall which puts into
perspective just how dangerous these
gigantic hulks of muscle really are and
since rancors are not native to tatooine
their introduction has wreaked havoc on
the local ecosystem
but much like grizzly bears there's
another side to the seemingly vicious
rancor
my studies suggest young rancors
actually imprint on whatever species
they first interact with during an early
period of development
imprinting isn't unheard of in earth's
animal kingdom and is present in young
birds especially but it might be a
little surprising to see such a behavior
in a beast as brutal as a rancor like
most creatures rancors are much more
complicated than they first appear
that being said there is one life form
in particular that i've been
apprehensive to study up close
in the pit of carcoon dwells the
carnivorous sarlacc appearing as a giant
mouth buried in the sand local testimony
indicates that under the surface the
sarlacc's body is over 300 feet or 100
meters long
a diagram from the field guide of the
interplanetary naturalist terrell
whitlatch gives us a more complete look
at the sarlacc's body underneath the
sand this diagram shows us that feeding
tentacles extend from the creature's
posterior end drawing in nutrients from
the surrounding sand like the roots of a
plant indeed the ever-confounding
sarlacc may be more plant than animal
but the sarlacc still feeds on live prey
that falls into its fanged mouth
while an organism relying on prey to
fall directly into its domain might
sound strange one species on earth does
something quite similar this pit belongs
to an ant lion an insect eating predator
that digs steep holes in the sand that
almost look like miniature sarlacc pits
the antlion waits at the bottom of the
trap for an ant to tumble down the slope
which the ant lion then slowly devours
curiously there are similar rumors that
the sarlacc also digests its food over a
long period of time but the only way to
determine whether or not this is true is
to get a closer look
so i'm lowering a flashlight equipped
camera inside the creature's gullet this
is a nerve-wracking operation as the
beast might awaken and attack the light
at any moment navigating the camera down
a stomach cavity i find it's difficult
to see anything turning on the
high-powered beam we've found the
half-digested remains of an unlucky
former meal while gross this discovery
seems to confirm the theory of the
sarlacc slow digestive system
unfortunately it seems the sarlacc has
had enough of our prodding and turns
aggressive time to quickly pull the
camera back up to the surface and leave
this place forever
on tatooine one might assume the sarlacc
would be the top predator but there is a
single final life form on this planet
large enough to eat sarlacc while
refueling at a town i notice the sand
begins to vibrate when the ground shakes
like this
every life form from the tiny scurriers
to the largest banthas know it means
trouble one older bantha isn't quick
enough from the ground bursts an
enormous predator which vanishes just as
quickly with its meal that was a crate
dragon the most elusive and deadly
creature on tatooine
the bones of juvenile crate dragons can
sometimes be glimpsed upon the dunes but
when great dragons reach their adult
form they're virtually invincible this
will be a very challenging species to
study indeed
reuniting with the tuscan clan from
earlier i agree to travel with them to
the site of a crate dragon cave the
tuscans make a pilgrimage here regularly
as they've studied its digestive cycle
for generations and feed the beast
banthas to keep it satiated
from the depths of the cave the creature
emerges
this time the dragon seems satisfied
with its meal and retreats back under
the sand
for now
according to the tuscans the krait
dragons have another terrifying habit
when they feel threatened projecting
corrosive venom directly from their
mouths which causes their target to
dissolve
while spitting venom might seem unusual
there are several species of spitting
cobras that have a similar defense when
threatened these snakes can contract
muscles around their venom glands and
launch venom from their needle-like
fangs
and like the krait dragon some spitting
cobras can launch their deadly venom
more than three times the length of
their bodies crate dragon venom however
isn't true venom but an acidic fluid
that helps them digest their food
we're fortunate that the crate dragon
wasn't in a spitting mood today
yet one way or another eventually
everything on tatooine meets its end to
the south an adult crate dragon has died
and other species benefit from the
resources its body leaves behind
the clan i'm traveling with is
particularly effective at breaking down
the different parts of these leviathans
after they expire but there is one body
part in particular they seem to be
searching for a young hunter has found a
rare krait dragon pearl these pearls are
formed the same way as the pearls of
earth mollusks the process begins when a
small irritant like a grain of sand
finds its way inside the life form a
crystallized substance known as [ __ ]
then forms around the irritant and over
time the layers build up and form a
pearl
but it's an uncommon occurrence in krait
dragons and hence finding this valuable
pearl is a tremendous triumph for the
clan
it's been an incredible trek across
tatooine while all life forms here have
to endure the same conditions no two
life forms have adapted to this planet's
unique challenges in the same way we've
learned much about these survival
strategies on our expedition but with
the twin suns high in the afternoon sky
the time has come at last to say goodbye
to this unexpectedly teeming planet
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support to help make videos like this
possible by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you